this is kind of a follow-up to Bryce's
videos on deep burning so deep learning
is a kind of a big thing at the moment
and there's some disagreement between
research over whatever this is going to
be bit it's lit this is the big thing
that's going to change everything or
whether this is another fashion DiPaola
artificial neural networks were in the
80s everyone got very excited and they
got quite a good results and then they
realize that they couldn't solve all the
problems with them they don't know for
what it's worth
these are a big deal I think let's talk
about convoluted neural networks as I
said that convolutional neural networks
alright K they combine both deep neural
networks which is what whites are
talking about and kernel convolutions
which is what I talked about in a
previous video so I would probably
recommend people watch that video you
know entertaining hosts
right so but but because if you don't
know what a kernel convolution is this
isn't going to make most sense to you
okay so watch that video first so that's
the kernel convolution as we did on
graphics and things like so below yeah
so raw versus Gaussian blurs and things
like this okay so we operate to in
particular an interdiction so if we
think back to a traditional artificial
neural network okay what we've got is
we've got some kind of input we're
trying to learn okay we've got some
hidden layers right and then we've got
some output layers maybe there's this
one I don't know okay and we ambe's are
fully connected so we have lots of
connections from here and here and here
and then these are connected to here and
so on I'm just drawing in a few of them
and then these are all connected to the
end okay now using Bryce's analogy we're
talking about house prices okay so this
would be something like number of
bedrooms and this would be something
like it hasn't got a pool and this would
be you know what floor space is it and
has it got a good garden and so on lots
of these okay
lots of inner knows that we don't really
care about particularly I don't right
but then then and so on and so forth and
then finally at the end we have a house
price now what this house price is is a
complicated function of these inputs
it's complicated because this node here
is some linear or nonlinear now
combination of these okay so a bit of
this plus a bit of this plus a bit of
this plus a bit of this through some
non-linearity function this is a
different combination of these this
again different combination of these and
so on right and then this the different
combination is so you can see you're
building up some kind of level of
abstraction here where you've got
combinations of combinations
okay and that function is very
complicated when but I talked about a
black box in some ways that's exactly
what it is because we can't look at
these individual weights and say well
that's got point to of this one so that
must mean this because we just don't
know what it means right in the grand
scheme of things in this whole network
we don't know what that individual
weight means okay and to be honest we
might not even care that much what we
really care about is how well does it
predict house price how accurate is that
based on that for different inputs to
change this leave the output is it good
yes brilliant okay now for images which
is obviously what I spend most of my
time around this is a start
but it's not very useful to me if you
think that this is our inputs okay
and I give you a picture of house and I
say right tell me how much this house is
worth okay well what so how do i okay so
if there's two things I could do right
first of all I could try and calculate
things like number of bedrooms and stuff
based on the image and put them in here
in some way I'd be calculating some
features and then I'd be putting them in
here and learning on those features that
is quite a smart way of doing it because
apart from that's what is quite
difficult it's smart because we don't
have to have that many more neurons in
anything we can actually use the same
network as we used before for our model
on our house all we have to do is work
that work out the bit of code that does
image analysis now anyone that's trying
to find out the number of rooms in a
house based only on one picture of the
outside of the house will tell me that
that can't be done right that's hard
okay
so you could naively think what we could
do instead is just put the image in here
make this the first pixel and it's a
second pixel and this is the third pixel
and so on okay then this has got all the
information it could ever need right but
that's the problem okay seven megapixel
image about 7 million input nodes let's
say we have 7 million loads on the next
layer each one connects to each other
one you can see that that's just going
to melt my computer it's not even going
to try and create it it's too much
information ok
that's why we downsample our space a
little bit what we would usually do is
calculate some small subset of features
and then we put them in at this end so
that's quite important so traditional
machine learning is done a bit like that
so Michelle's done some videos on this
calculate some features about someone's
face and put that into some machine
learning algorithm
what you don't do is try and put the
machine learning algorithm just on the
face because there's too much
information there until now okay right
that's where convolutional neural
network step in so convolutional neural
networks replace each of these nodes
with a kernel convolution so like a
Sobel edge detector okay now so instead
of what I would have done before which
was run a Sobel over something and then
machine learn on that I just give this
the opportunity to learn which features
are interesting maybe is an edge
detection maybe it's a corner detection
maybe it's something that highlights
whatever's in the middle of the picture
okay or something to hire us for top
left-hand corner it doesn't really
matter and the point is I don't know
what they are right if I give you you
know two thousand pictures of houses and
asked you to predict house price based
on the pictures right I don't know for
sure I can guess but it might be to have
any windows it has and things like this
but I don't know for sure okay and a
computer can brute-force through those
things much quicker than I can and tell
me okay and then I can go I can both
predict it and I can look back and say
oh it was Windows after all so let's
imagine what we have is our image okay
so I'm going to move away from the house
analogy now because I'm going to have to
draw a lot of pictures of houses if I do
that okay so let's talk about how CNN
works and why it's useful so we have an
image of something now I have seen
convolutional neural networks used for
non images but for now we just talked
about images this is a picture of let's
say me it's you know it's not a great
likeness but I'll stick by it now there
are three channels here okay so this is
actually a 3d volume in some sense
remember when we talked about 3d images
you could view RGB as in some sense 3d
so the first plane is our our G and B or
vice versa
what we do is if we performed a Sobel
edge detection on this what it would do
is produce another image that was
slightly smaller than this and only one
deep so hypothetically it will be
another image where the edges let's say
the horizontal edges were highlighted so
it would kind of look like that or
something I don't know some half of my
face where the horizontal edges are
highlighted okay it's not a great
diagram but they would only be one
output because so bill just outputs a
number between naught and 255 something
to scale it
okay now the problem is that I don't
know that Sobel is the best thing for
this task it might be right it might be
useful to detect edges on house
to work out what the price are or if you
want to detect faces to detect the size
of the face it's that kind of makes
sense on the other hand it's going to
produce a lot of erroneous bits if I'm
sticking in front of a tree there's
gonna be loads of edge stuff going on
there that I don't care about in a
convolutional neural network what we do
is we do let's say 60 of these on the
first layer so we have one and then
behind it we have another one behind it
we have another one behind it we have
another one and so on going this way so
the first one will be some convolution
process applied to this whole image that
takes three input channels and outputs
one output channel the next will be a
different kernel convolution operation
so each of these will have a different
kernel those who are weights those are
these values here the instead of our
nagi back to normal learning and so
let's say we have sixty of those or 64
of those okay one of them might be
setting edges one of them might be
detecting corners and then we use them
as our features for learning now that's
a start but with this is deep learning
now right so what do we do now well what
we now do is we do more features based
on these features so we find
combinations of corners combinations of
edges that make something interesting my
face is not just a circle of edges what
it is is a number of corners and edges
and bits of texture and things all in a
specific shape that is unique to it well
certainly to a human face but even even
unique to me right
these are capable of distinguishing
between different people so this kernel
window will go down to this pixel here
okay so this will slide about this image
and produce this output image and then
the next one will do the same a next one
will do the same then we do the same
thing on this one let me do it in a
different pen so we can see better
here's my red kernel convolution and
this slides about and produces another
image which is a slight combination of
maybe corners and edges or something I
mean it is second-level it's not going
to abstract but we'll get the idea okay
so there's going to be some sort of
shape it's going to be sort of it's not
gonna make much sense to us but it'll
make some sense of this machine and
there'll be another of that set of these
so a lots of these right going back all
of these will look different and be some
different representation of my face
transformed in some way to be useful
okay and again I haven't picked these
these have been learned just like a
normal deep learning algorithm so I
haven't had to say I definitely think
edges of important for this because I
don't know for sure
this goes on and we keep doing it and
sometimes we also downsample the sides
of these images just to save memory but
won't dwell on that too much and because
of the way that we down sample and the
way that sometimes these convolution
operation slightly shrink the image
because they don't go all the way to the
edge all right if you've got a 5x5
kernel you can't go to the edge two
pixels because you're going off the edge
so we don't worry about that which gets
slightly smaller in the end we end up
with a much smaller image and lots of
features going on way back so these are
my different convolutions of
convolutions of convolutions of
convolution and each one will look
different and represent something
different and we don't know what that is
so this one could be highlighted when
it's a face in the middle or it could be
dark when it isn't
this one might be highlighted when
there's an ear at a certain position and
so on eventually these will get down to
being just one pixel and very very long
so essentially what we've done there is
we've completely removed the spatial
dimension there's no more spatial
information left we don't know where
anything is but we know what it is
because it's listed and all these
features these now of our newer ones at
the end so we have a couple more layers
that point to these and then finally we
have one at the end that says is this a
picture of Mike's face okay and it
produces a 1 if it is and the 0 if it
isn't and then what we do is just like a
normal Network we train it so we say
here the picture is not me
ok so this should be a 1 and let's say
it's an or point 5 because kind of
random so we adjust these weights and we
adjust the weights inside all these
kernel convolutions since the adjustment
having manually know it happens using a
well it's coded in but it's usually
performed by library and it's using a
process called back propagation so what
we do is we basically predict what
direction we have to move the weights in
to improve our output and then we move
them over slightly in that direction and
we have to do it in reverse order
because these ones depend on these ones
depend on these ones and vice versa what
we do is we say well look given that
I've said it's nor point 5 percent
chance of Mike and we want to one how do
I change these weights here to get
slightly closer to one and I do it and
then I say how do I change these again
to do even better and so on and I work
my way back ok that kind of mass we're
not gonna go into a lot of these things
of implemented in libraries so as a
researcher I mean much as I'd like to
implement some of these things it takes
quite a long time just because
programming takes a while right and
and it's better for me just to apply
these things and get good results than
it is for me to invent me invent the
wheel all the time constantly if
everyone was programming the same things
over and over again
normal get anything done like cuz I have
to start by programming up Linux to get
to get I'm not claiming I can by the way
and and so on so you know let's not
reinvent the wheel so I do this I send
them let's say a thousand pictures 500
which are me you know so I've been to a
photo shoot or something no and 500
which you're not and I train it to the
convolutions and these weights on the
output are such that it gets one when
there's a picture of me and not when it
isn't okay and then I can look at these
convolutions and say what is it about me
that's distinctive and it's probably
going to be finding you know weird
shaped on my face like it's a bit of a
weird shape so it things that are unique
to me now in a more general situation
there's a big database called image net
right they have a competition every year
to see who can classify these images the
best so dogs cats planes trees and so on
okay they're all in there and there's a
thousand or so images of each right so
we have a really big network but it's
much bigger than this little one I drew
and we say right let's throw millions of
images at this my thousands of cats
thousands of dogs and we have lots more
outputs than just the one and we say
what is it and it's it's a dog and is
convolutional neural networks have been
around for a little while but they've
really started we begin about 2012 when
it when someone came along applied one
of these to image net and got incredible
results and so on and so forth and now
there's this big push and everyone's
trying to get even better results the
embedded science now I work on more of
the applied end computer science so I'm
more interested in how this affects
plant science and things like this
so that's what we're working on but the
kind of results we're seeing are really
really impressive
so I mean case in point I've done I've
done some root tip detection so
detection of root tips in images of
plants and I've got some software but I
already programmed and the kind of done
a low-level feature detector approach to
detecting root tips and it's about
seventy percent okay which is what you
would expect because maybe some boot
hair gets confused as to root tip or a
bit of blotch of dirt or maybe there's
just too little tips really close
together when it gets confused okay this
the CNN I trained is 98% accurate and it
finds them with 99%
see it doesn't make many mistakes and
that's over thousands of images so does
that mean the work you've done already
just goes out the window yeah yeah no
took to an extent yes so in 20 cent know
you need expertise to be able to craft
for network and train it and prepare the
images and there's obviously work to be
done and there's some disagreement over
how much of a problem you can solve a
convolution on your network right so
there are lots more things you can do
with roots beyond finding tips can you
do all of them with a convolutional
neural network I don't know we'll see
I'll be trying but we'll see ok maybe
not so maybe what you do is you use this
as a tool just like other machine
learning algorithms we're being a
package that does lots of other things
as well on the other hand if you're just
doing cat and dog detection you might as
well use the CNN because it's going to
do better even if against the other
purpose for which the botnet can use its
BOTS is for distributed computing now
some objects obviously are more amenable
to this than others but the more images
we get the better it is there's no depth
involved here at all ok